charlotte hornets forward joining us on
the program Frank how are you today I'm
doing a while are you I'm doing
spectacular did you watch the finals
last night I did I did indeed and your
thoughts I thought that last night
proved Howard how great LeBron is them
throughout his entire career and I think
that was a culminating point for him and
his team and the team he said he was
going to win a title for you faced the
Cavs four times the Warriors two times
if I guess can you put into words what
it's like to face both of these teams um
it's crazy you know I was able to see
different sides of both teams I think
when we played Golden State at home it
was a pretty tight game then steph had
like 27 in the third quarter and didn't
even play in the forest and they flew us
out when we play the cavs we had some
tight games we won one of the games in
other games they really just took over
so you got to see different aspects of
both teams and it's just so cool that I
get to play against some of the best
basketball players in the world have you
covered LeBron I did a couple times I'm
going to be completely honest the first
time it happened I was really nervous
but after that got more comfortable what
happened when you gardening I just tried
to make him shoot jump shot you see how
well it goes for him when he's back in
the room and you can see how far I think
they could see him when he's making a
jump shot like you did the last three
games so I mean you really put it
together in the finals what's that like
though as big as he is because I'm sure
there aren't many other players you can
compare to that style and that ability
and agility that LeBron has
I mean some of the place you made last
night just proves you know how big of a
physical freaky is you know that block
in transition on equal dollar was was
insane you know I think if he would have
made that that dump at the end of the
game on dream on I think that would have
been one of the greatest dunks in NBA
history no just give him time and
situation and I think he just really
proved you know how great of a
basketball player how great of an
athlete he is in the series what did
Cleveland do defensively with this
splash brothers oh no it looked like
they were kind of just rotating people
on you know they were switching a lot
making them switching at the three-point
line and trying to make them stay out as
far as they can you know I mean they're
gonna hit tough shots they hit close
shot last night but I think they put a
lot of emphasis on trying to take them
out of the game in which they ultimately
did you know which left you know
draymond open and he hit a bunch of
shots and employed really really well
but I think for the Warriors to win like
they needed to they needed stuff and
clay to be making you know a bunch of
shots and Cleveland was able to take
that away he's Frank Kaminsky the
Hornets forward joining a stamp Patrick
show what was more tense for you the
final moments of the finals or Game of
Thrones last night I was much more
hamper game of throne and it wasn't even
close okay how big is this show amongst
players in the locker room um I mean
there's a handful of people that watch
it um no there's a lot of staff that
washes it too I try to have as many
conversations as I possibly can about it
with anyone who wants to talking about
it so you can drive so many series and
so many things that I see and I like to
point out but the other then there's
just some people who just don't like the
show at all so which i call them stupid
because I think it's the best show of
all time you and make love and have
something in common then you guys can
geek out about this is that right Nick
lovin oh yeah we were on hold before he
was just as nervous as I was last night
dead it was very tense
it was it was most intense episode so
far is there a character who is in Game
of Thrones two would be LeBron um yeah
I'd say Jon Snow probably that's
probably a a good comparison I mean Jon
Snow's doesn't get the hate that LeBron
does but I mean I think they're
comparable well both came back from the
dead yeah that's true for uh it's just
for uh for not being as loved as you
know other people were you know they
prove themselves to be great what
mclovin ok since I have Frank every time
he's been on I've asked him one question
and I'm gonna ask him again who do you
think Jon Snow's father is leave it
there uh-oh Rhaegar Targaryen bingo wait
who is out it's that peter dinklage it's
not obligated ok yeah I've never seen an
episode Frank so I I know that there's
similar while you're making you're
making a big mistake yeah I have other
things to watch Frank but I can say oh I
can start now I mean it's just don't
don't be you know this like game of
throne snob there I'll eventually get
around to it is so Steph Curry Khaleesi
um I don't know because yes i mean i
love Khaleesi but she hasn't really done
much yet so and stuff is accomplished a
lot so that's a tough comparison ok
alright that's the only other character
I know I I know Jon Snow and Khaleesi I
don't even know Peter Dinklage whose
character there that's that's all in it
that's all I know yeah I'll get around
to remain one pretty much yeah I'll get
around to one it took me 10 years to
watch breaking bad Frank so it's gonna
take me a little while yeah see but I
have so much time to do nothing so this
is what I do in my free time alright if
I said you could have a cameo in Game of
Thrones a speaking role in Game of
Thrones
or make the all-star team hello that's
tough I think you just answered it Frank
there there are a lot of guys or girls
to gotta go I gotta go all fair game but
see there'll be plenty of years for me
to have the opportunity to make an
all-star team game of thrones as a fun
game of thrones has an expiration date
and I think it's going to be within the
next couple years so to be in that show
would be unbelievable in my eyes even if
you died even if I even if I have one
line and I get shot or hit with an arrow
design that would be fine with me huh
even if just my face is in it I'd be an
extra we'll work on that Frank art be
unbelievable they enjoy the offseason
great to talk to you again thanks for
joining us yep good at art you to take
care that's Frank Kaminsky right there
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience